all right look at that guys right there
you can see we just finished playing for
two hours 60 point 7 f PS on this 350
dollar PC build that is just insane
let's go bro what's up you don't get out
of here bro look at that are you serious
come on man look at this dude what I
have sitting right down there is our
custom three hundred and fifty dollar PC
yes that's right only three hundred and
fifty dollars for the whole PC the case
the motherboard processor graphics card
everything and what we're gonna do in
this video is we're gonna play call of
duty warzone the very popular battle
royale game right here and we're gonna
see how much FPS we get and this is only
possible thanks to the brand-new
processor from AMD
it's the Rison 3100 for only $100 you
get four cores and eight threads so it's
the perfect budget gaming processor now
before we get into the actual gameplay I
want to mention a couple of things for
only 350 dollars you can't really expect
that much because we just got the bare
minimums for all the specs to get it to
that price point so down in the
description below I'm gonna have a bunch
of Amazon links to some better
alternatives just in case you have some
extra cash beyond three hundred and
fifty dollars and one last thing I want
to mention that we already made a step
by step build guide on how to build this
$350 PC by yourself so if you're
interested in this PC definitely check
that video out after this one let's get
right into cod war zone so I already
played this a couple times and I found
the optimal settings for this
ridiculously cheap $350 PC we've got
1080p resolution no framerate limit
we've got the textures on normal shadows
on low all of these settings disabled
that freely don't matter in a game
especially for battle royale alright so
check this out I don't know if you guys
can see but running at about 59 fps went
down to 49 at times so it's definitely
not perfect but I mean three hundred and
fifty bucks you know what are you gonna
expect
all right got one dude oh no I need a
reload got him look at that 57 FPS I saw
right there so sometimes we're hitting
60 FPS here 64-62 but we are going down
around 51 right now 49 I think the
lowest I usually see is 48 but overall
it still feels smooth pretty smooth
definitely fine for gaming and then
considering that a lot of console is
that these people are playing on they're
getting 30 FPS got him yes so we're
getting this FPS I mean look at that 60
FPS right now got him oh yeah so overall
I'm really impressed with that
performance we were hitting a bare
minimum of about 48 fps and sometimes we
were getting up to 70 but usually we
stayed about 55 FPS average so that's
not bad for the $350 bare minimum PC
setup so what I'm gonna do is put in
another 8 gig stick of RAM this is 35
bucks if you want to add that into your
budget
alright so I just put that ramen
literally took me two seconds as you can
see we've got two sticks of eight gigs
right there let's get back into the game
alright so here we are and we're still
looking like getting the same FPS 5354
come on get out of here don't tied to
his need almost died so far it seems
like the single stick of RAM wasn't
really limiting us that much because I'm
still seeing it drop down 40 FPS so I
don't think that is an issue we got him
so the RAM didn't really do that much
let's pop in that 580 graphics card and
see how it does all right guys I just
swapped in that 580 right there you can
see it rx 580 I didn't even have to
update the drivers alright so here we
are instantly you guys can see we're
getting a hundred and twenty-two FPS 120
this is great for that small change of
going with the alternative
graphics card look at that 156 158
that's insane
Oh actually God the dude you see that
dude get out of here what are you guys
doing man 110 FPS right now this is
great massive difference compared to the
560 what I'm gonna do in just a minute
I'm gonna try out for K but let's play
like this for a little bit honestly with
that risin 3100 processor it's just so
incredibly consistent such a good deal a
hundred bucks four cores eight threads
oh god um still over a hundred FPS
really smooth right now this is awesome
4k resolution 3840 by 2160 let's do it
got two of them get about that the same
FPS that we used to get before alright
so now that we're a 4k we're getting
about 55 56 49 48 fps
yes got the dude so let's actually go
down to 1440p alright so there you guys
go looking at it 70 to 78 FPS much much
better we're not going below 60 at all
I'm actually gonna go into the settings
and let's swap those texture resolutions
up to high these two right here oh
that's still at 70 69 somebody's
shooting at me Oh through the window
come on man yo alright so I switched
back to 1080p just seeing how much FPS
we can get 117 right there 113 let's go
bro what's up go get out of here bro
look at that are you serious come on man
look at this dude so as you guys can see
from our fps 125 right there feels very
smooth thanks to the 3100 processor come
on yep got him yes
got him he got a head shot there you
guys have it that's the build we have
all the parts down in the description
below and you guys can click right
there to check out the build guide to
see how we built it because it's
actually really simple this is the most
simple build that we've ever done so
definitely check that out hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video let us know what
you think about it down in the comment
section below and click that circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]